finding a suitable job in the field of
machine learning is becoming
increasingly difficult
ideal way to display your machine
learning skills is through
put portfolio of projects will
illustrate that you can utilize those
machine learning skills in your profile
Web projects like movie recommendation
systems fake news detection and many
more are the best way to improve your
early programming skills you may have
the knowledge but putting it to use it
what keeps you competitive according to
recent studies aim and machine learning
job related postings have increased by
344 percent in the last five years
companies across the globe are seeking
professionals who can harness the power
of data and build intelligent systems
the average salary is hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in the United States
and 15 lakh rupees in India so there is
no better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you are looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques like machine
learning algorithm development and
unsupervised learning look no further
than a Caltech postgraduate program in
Ai and machine learning in partnership
with IBM this Ai and machine learning
course covers the latest tools and
Technologies from the AI ecosystem and
features master classes by Caltech
faculty and IBM exports hackathons and
ask me anything sessions
this program showcases caltex ATM is
excellence and IBM's industry prowse the
artificial intelligence course covers
key Concepts like statistics data
science with python machine learning
deep learning NLP and reinforcement
learning through an Interactive Learning
model with live session so enroll now
and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is in the
description box below with that having
said hey everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel in this video we
are going to cover 8 machine learning
projects to make your portfolio stand
out but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share so
here are 8 machine learning projects
that can increase the reach of your
portfolio and enable you to acquire a
job as a machine learning engineer
at number eight we have a loan approval
prediction system in this project
focused on machine learning we aim to
analyze and predict the outcome of the
loan approval process for individuals
we'll tackle this as a classification
problem where we aim to determine
whether a loan will be approved or not
classification problems involve
predicting class labels for given input
data examples and they Encompass various
tasks like identifying spam mails
detecting cancer and Performing
sentiment analysis to gain a better
understanding of classification problem
and learn how to construct a loan
prediction system you can refer to the
project link provided in the description
box below
at number 7 we have a fake news
detection system can you trust
everything you encounter on social media
it's a fact that not all news is
reliable right so how can you identify
fake news machine learning holds the key
by engaging in this project focused on
detecting fake news you will gain the
ability to differentiate between real
and fabricated information this machine
learning project focuses on Discerning
between fake and True News we employ a
tfid vectorizer from the SK learn
library on a data set the model is then
trained using a pre-initialized passive
aggressive classifier ultimately the
accuracy score and confusion Matrix
indicator models performance for further
details you can find the project Link in
the description box below
at number six we have the personality
prediction system the concept revolves
around using machine learning techniques
to determine an individual's personality
a person's personality has a significant
impact on both their personal and
professional life nowadays many
companies are selecting candidates based
on their personality traits leading to
increased job efficiency as individuals
are assigned tasks that align with their
strength rather than being forced into
unsuitable rules in our study we aim to
combine ml techniques like SVD knife
base and logistic regression to predict
a person's personality additionally we
utilize the phase frequency method to
forecast their talents this model or
approach enables users to easily
identify their personality traits and
Technical abilities to delve deeper into
this project please refer to the link
provided in the description box below
at number 5 we have Parkinson's disease
system Parkinson's disease is a
progressive disorder of the central
nervous system that impacts movements
and lead to symptoms like Tremors and
stiffness it consists of five stages and
affects over 1 million individuals
worldwide annually in this machine
learning project our objective is to
develop an svm support Vector Machine
model using various python modules such
as secret learn numpy pandas and SVU
will import the data extract the
features and labels scale the features
split the data set design the svm model
and evaluate its accuracy
ultimately will utilize the developed
model to assess the presence of
Parkinson's disease in an individual for
further details on this project please
refer to the link provided in the
description box below at number 4 we
have sentimental analysis
sentiment analysis also known as opinion
mining involves the straightforward task
of asserting the author's emotions or
attitudes expressed in a given text it
aims to decipher the underlying
intentions of the user when they write
something to identify potential personal
information we utilize a range of
natural language processing and text
analysis techniques a goal is to detect
extract and quantify such information
from the text enabling classification
and data manipulation in this project
we'll leverage the Amazon customer
review data set for conducting sentiment
analysis for further insights into this
project please refer to the link
provided in the description box below at
number 3 we have image classification
using CNN deep learning is an immensely
popular and rapidly growing field in the
present times numerous projects and
problem statements across various
domains heavily rely on deep learning
techniques when confronted with a
computer vision problem many of us
including myself would opt for
conventional neural network as the go to
deep learning approach in this
particular project will employ
convolutional neural networks to develop
an image processing project and gain
insights into its capabilities and the
reasons behind its widespread popularity
will delve into each stage of creating a
convolutional model and embark on a
first remarkable project for this
project we'll utilize the cipher 10 data
set which is commonly employed for image
classification tasks to acquire further
information about this project please
refer to the link provided in the
description box below
at number 2 we have a face recognition
system the remarkable advancement in
technology never ceases to stun people
as they continuously introduce
incredible inventions that enhance
convenience and comfort in our lives
among these Innovation face recognition
has proven to be the least intrusive and
faster form of biometric verification
over the EO this project will utilize
the opencv and phase recognition
libraries to develop a phase detection
system opencv offers a powerful set of
tools libraries and hardware for
real-time computer vision applications
with opencv we can create ospiring
projects in real time to gain insights
into the process of building a phase
recognition system please refer to the
link provided in the description box
below
and last but not the least we have a
movie recommendation system in today's
world most people rely on technology to
stream movies and TV shows however
deciding what to watch next can
sometimes be disheartening thankfully
recommendation systems based on viewers
viewing history and preferences have
become commonplace these recommendations
are powered by Machine learning and can
be an enjoyable and accessible projects
for beginners pairing programmers can
practice coding in either python or R
languages using data from movie lens
data set which more than 6000 users
generated if you are interested in
learning how to create personalized
movie recommendations for yourself or
your loved ones you can find the project
Link in the description box below so
these were the eight ml projects you
could start your career in machine
learning thank you so much for being
here today if you enjoyed this video
please subscribe to our YouTube channel
and give a like to this video thank you
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign